so much for that introduction and thank
you for inviting me to come it's great
great to be here today I hope to uh
inform you a little bit about the this
uh project uh maybe inspire you to do
something along related lines I think
the result that we have so far are just
an inkling that it might be possible to
do something it might be possible to do
things that would uh help nudge people
towards occasionally considering or
exposing themselves to uh to challenging
viewpoints uh maybe there'll be a few
entertaining things along the way and at
the end I'm going to ask for your advice
about a couple of things both uh the
next experiment that we're going to run
a few details of it might as well pick
your brains uh and uh also since we're
here in Silicon Valley I want to get any
ideas you might have about um business
opportunities uh can is there somebody
who will pay to get to uh to uh get
people to have uh diverse uh diverse
exposure to exposure to diverse
political viewpoints so the work that
I'm going to talk about today is uh
several different pieces
um much of it uh or two of the pieces uh
were uh joint with Shan Munson uh there
were parts of his dissertation work uh
when he was a doctoral student with me
at Michigan he's now an assistant
professor at Washington um the last
project I'm going to talk about is with
Sunil Park who was um he was a PhD
student at kaon in Korea and then a
postto working with me now he's at
telica and I've been influenced a lot uh
by another former doctoral student who
graduated some years ago now he's an
associate professor at Ohio State uh
who's in the communications department
and and sort of went deeper into
thinking about the um you know what is
what are the uh what do communication
scholars in political sciences know
about this Arena so preview
here it's for society if people who are
liberal occasionally read stuff that is
mostly read by conservatives it's also
good for society if people who are
conservative in their Viewpoint
occasionally read things that are mostly
read by liberals and that maybe that's
not happening quite as much as it as
would be good for society
although uh it may not be as bad as some
of the pundits are saying in terms of
how polarized we are certainly uh there
it would be good if if we had a little
bit more exposure to challenge and then
I I'm going to go through three efforts
that we've made to try to nudge people
push them a little bit towards getting
more exposure to to challenging
viewpoints uh one of those is to Simply
reflect back to people here's what
you're you've actually been exposed
to a second is to provide uh a news
aggregator that lists a bunch of
articles for today
uh where in one version of that those
articles are sorted and highlighted to
make it easier for you to find the ones
that you'll agree with or disagree with
and the third is uh giving you a bunch
of articles on one story on one topic
that come from different sources and
when we do that is it better to uh to
sort them by the IDE the ideology of the
source or is it better to just mix them
up
so societal benefits of challenge
exposure there there are a few Arguments
for why this is going to be better for
society um one is that uh people who are
exposed to more viewpoints will be able
to recite more of those viewpoints
they'll have a larger argument
repertoire about what are the what are
the claims that some people are making
on controversial issues immigration
reform let's say uh and that that
increased argument repertoire will a
lead to more
tolerance uh of people who disagree and
some moderation if you sort of see the
issue from multiple sides it's a little
bit harder to to hold on to a really
extreme
Viewpoint another claim is that uh when
we have
uh when we have
uh people who think that they're in a
majority but they're
not they get really angry when policy
decisions go against
them I I think we should we should end
the death penalty I think it's a really
bad
policy I it hasn't
happened I could think that there's a
terrible
conspiracy of people who are keeping
that going
it actually turns out though that you
look at the opinion polls most people
don't agree with
me and so I have to when I understand
that they don't agree with me it makes
me a little bit less likely to come up
with a conspiracy theory for why my
position isn't the law so this is a you
know another reason why we end up
getting a little bit less um
fragmentation a little bit less uh
uh ripping a part of society if people
understand when sometimes they're losing
because actually they're in the
minority now uh this this idea that we
may be uh not getting enough exposure
has gotten a lot of play um in March of
2011 Ellie Pariser gave a TED talk as a
way to start publicizing his book the
filter bubble a quick poll here how many
of you have seen this Ted talk or read
his book or otherwise know of this
filter bubble
argument okay so the the bubble is a
metaphor the idea is that uh that uh
when you're inside the bubble you only
see certain kinds of things and the
things that are outside the bubble are
are are not uh are not visible to you
and uh so if you're inside the bubble
you'll only see the things that already
agree with you that you won't have
Serendipity you won't have awareness of
of what's going on uh for for for what
other people are
seeing now there is some evidence that's
out there about how polarized online
news reading actually is and it's it's
not it is not as bad as uh as Pariser
would would make it out so for example G
Cen Shapiro in their corly Journal of
Economics article they they
um they classif they scored sources Fox
News New York Times various blogs um by
the percentage of the audience for those
sources that identify themselves as
conservative conservative or liberal and
then if you look at the
people who describe themselves are
liberal or conservative and see what
sources they're going
to overall there more people slightly
more conservatives than liberals in this
country so 50% of the
audience
for Publications overall is is uh is uh
if you take a s a sample of everybody
you look at all the Publications that
they look at those those uh Publications
have a 57% conservative audience if you
take just the Liberals and see which
things they're looking at their
audiences have 53% conservative so there
is a tilt and the conservatives are
going to sites that have 60% 61%
conservative audience so there is a
difference and and they they quantify
this difference between the these
sources that the Liberals and
conservatives are seeing uh and then
they try to compare it to some other
places where there might be polarization
like uh what
newspapers uh print newspapers people
are looking at or even some measures of
face-o face ideological SE segregation
yeah just because it seems interesting
it seems symmetric um that is neither
side seems to be listening more to just
their side than the other ones at least
by this by these num not obviously from
this yeah interesting yeah uh of course
we all think that our side's actually
pretty good about checking the other
side but the other side is never is just
staying in their bubble um the the other
really interesting point they found is
that the real divide is between people
who uh follow political news and people
who
don't so the average um Yahoo news
reader is less likely to re to also read
the New York Times than the average
reader of a farri
Blog the people who are reading brib
Bart they're also looking at the New
York Times more often than people who
read
news uh so these are these are some
stories that say yeah there is there are
some differences maybe it's not quite as
as scary as as um as Pariser would make
it out but Pariser is also arguing
something about uh
Trends and that the better our tools get
the more we're likely to to end up in
these bubbles now these concerns are not
new in fact this group lens paper that
Michael was referring to the the one
that was presented at CCW in 1994 one of
our little paragraphs was okay you know
if we if we had lots of recommender
systems will there be a problem that
we'll all be getting the stuff that we
like and and we'll split into the global
village will split into these tribes our
conclusion was that actually it might
not be so bad because you might split
into tribes but there might be a lot of
cross
fertilization what's that what your
1994 and what this this question was
coming up before this right cuz when
Negra panti was proposing his stuff
right Negra panti was talking I think I
think it Negra ponti is a little bit
later I I don't remember that what's the
year of this being
digital okay so so so 91 so maybe that's
why we were inspired I don't remember
why we thought of it it ended up being
those you know two paragraphs in the
paper but so Pon is talking about
the daily me and that we can have these
personalized digital newspapers he was
he
this is 995 okay but he was writing
about it and talking about it certainly
for a few years before so anyway these
things were in the air the idea that we
were going to have personalization and
the concerns that maybe with
personalization something bad was going
to happen fracturing of the global
village or um no
Serendipity uh and so you know negron's
idea was you're going to have a little
dial that says uh only personalize this
much give me some stuff that that uh
that'll come from from everybody else C
sunstein and this is I should have put
years on on these things but uh this is
I think around
2000 uh he's he's writing uh
republic.com saying uh this is this is
going to be really bad people online
people are going to be able to get what
they want and what they want is only
stuff that they already agree with in
the era of newspapers they couldn't just
get what they want and so everything was
okay but now people are going to be able
to get what they want and it's it's
going to be horrible
so I'm I'm arguing that this is not new
with Pariser but um but there is a
different response there's much more
public resonance this is the these are
the reviews about Cass sunstein book uh
this I got took these a couple years ago
um a couple people liked it but there's
a whole lot of one-star things and they
say not the internet I know or he's an
authoritarian trying to interfere with
with free
speech um
this is the response to uh to Ellie
Pariser a lot more favorable here uh 479
this is this is now old statistics but
you know almost half a million views for
his for his video it got mostly positive
review in the New York Times a separate
contributed oped article uh rave reviews
on Amazon thank God the internet is hi
isn't hiding the filter bubble from me
an absolute must read for anyone who
uses the internet left or right shrewd
thoughtful and well executed insight
into the downside of Internet
personalization by the way Sergey Bren
and Larry Pages talk about half as many
views um yeah not everybody who who
watched the video reviewed the
book um so he's he's got he's even has a
little new parlor game comp of comparing
search engine results if any of you
tried doing this to see how personalized
your results ads are so he says um in
the spring of 2010 while the remains of
the deep waterer Horizon oil rig were
spewing crude oil into the Gulf of
Mexico I asked two friends to search for
the term
BP they're pretty similar educated white
left leaning women who live in the
Northeast but the results they saw were
quite different one of my friends saw
investment information about BP the
other saw news for one the first page of
results contained links about the oil
spill for the other there was nothing
about it except for a promotional ad for
P so that's his um that's his concern
and
uh have any of you tried doing this so
you you you can you you'll get different
results uh I'll get results you know
from University of Michigan and you'll
get results from Stanford and I'll think
wow you know University of Michigan is
doing really well in the in uh in the
scholarly Community everyone
everything's linking to us and you guys
think think that Stanford's doing really
well everything's looking to
you trying to quantify the knobs to look
at how your Google results are different
based on you know your race or age or
where they coming from That's notos
So search engine that let you kind of
change those
param changing based on the parameters
yeah and there there's going to be this
uh interesting workshop at icwsm this
year on sort of auditing algorithms of
taking the the classic sort of auditing
studies where they try to see whether um
you know auditing studies in social
science have been things like uh sending
resumés for jobs uh with that are
identical except one has an ethnic name
and the other doesn't and see you know
how How likely are you to to get a job a
call back for for the job so this is
trying to do that are the equivalent for
algorithms and and that that that study
is is you know doing it for search
engines but there are all kinds of
algorithms where we might like to see on
average do they perform differently for
women or men or do they perform
differently for for people in this
country or another country so there's
enough residents that you know you can
go to duck duck goo and they their whole
advertising as a search engine is we
don't bubble you or or track you we'll
give you non-personalized
results okay and they have a little
cartoon
story okay you want to see it Escape
your search engine filter bubble I have
I've given part of it is look at the
horrible thing that happens if you go to
Bing one person gets one thing somebody
else gets gets something
else but uh if you if you go search for
Barack Obama then and gets MSNBC and
aaine gets Fox News but that won't
happen if you come and use our search
engine so so there's a lot of resonance
a lot of concern that this is that this
is a problem and of course um this
personalized filtering isn't just when
you search it's also just when you use
your your Facebook
Newsfeed they don't they don't uh tell
us exactly how they're doing it but
they're taking into account which things
you click on and Ellie Pariser has you
know has a nice story of uh he says he
tries to you know he's he's very liberal
but he he was one of the founders of
movon he says he tries to cultivate
having some conservative friends but he
can't help himself he's more likely to
actually click on the things that that
come from his liberal friends and
somehow Facebook has now decided that
they're just going to hide all of the
stuff that's posted by his conservative
friends all right so what do we know um
in the social science literature
about what people really want do they
want just to get uh stuff that already
agrees with them and uh there's one
theory that says um yes uh they they
want to get things that reinforce what
they already know and one explanation
for this is a confirmation bias that
it's not just in news whatever you
happen to know you're likely to go out
seeking information that will uh confirm
that you're right rather than go out and
seeking information that
will make you change your
mind uh there's Al a theory that people
are deliberately trying to avoid things
that will make them feel bad like things
that tell them what you thought isn't
right uh this goes back to a theory of
of cognitive dissonance of of festinger
and uh that that people don't like this
feeling of cognitive dissonance and
they'll try to they'll try to take
actions to avoid it however there is
some uh there is some evidence that
people in some circumstances do uh are
open to challenge one is when they just
need to know whether they need to know
what's true they need to know whether
what they were what they were previously
thinking is right they're about to go to
uh they're about to go to Thanksgiving
dinner and they know they're going to
have to defend their opinion with their
in-laws who uh who are who have
different opinions so they figure they
better get a few a few bits of
information on their
side there also uh people are open to
challenge when they're when they're
feeling
secure so uh it's okay I I can handle a
little bit of challenge now because it's
not it's it's not it's not so
threatening and uh when they're feeling
like it's not an either or I can have
stuff that will that will agree with me
and I'll get some stuff that that
doesn't agree with me uh and so remember
that idea because that's going to be the
the seed for one of our intervention
ideas that we think maybe uh getting
people to to consider other opinions in
the context where they also have easy
access to opinions that they agree with
may be may be one strategy there's also
uh while we may have some behaviors that
we exhibit that we look at a bunch of
things in our news feed and don't click
on the stuff that seems like it's going
to be offensive to us um we may believe
that we ought
to there is a societal Norm that we
should be
balanced and that may be something that
we can appeal to when people make
explicit decisions deciding about what
their future information diet is going
to be they may they may be influenced to
choose consistently with this Norm even
though in the moment they
don't so remember that idea too because
that's going to be the in fact that's
going to be the seed for for this first
for this first idea so I'm now going to
talk about three three uh ways to try to
nudge people the first one is just to
give people some feedback so if we think
that they have that they're following
this or they believe in this Norm of
balanced exposure but in the minute to
minute they're not following their
long-term desires then maybe giving them
some feedback about what they're
actually doing will help them to
remind them to to do what they wanted
what they wanted to do in the long term
so we give them some feedback and we do
it in in a way that um sort of reminds
people of the norm so balance is good
unbalanced is
bad uh we made a browser extension and
you can see up in this in the upper
right hand corner there's a little
icon uh and that's our balanced man and
when you click on it you get to see him
um unbalanced is bad you're going to
fall off the tight RPP and
die and then we have a few others
getting to more balanced you're very
happy everything's good and if you're of
course unbalanced the other way you're
again you're unhappy because you're
going to die okay so we have these 11
cartoon figures and we show you one of
these figures depending on what your
history has
been so how do we determine which of
these 11 figures well we have a a coding
of all the sources or many
sources uh we've got a number to assign
to the New York Times and another one to
decide to think progress and another one
to assign to slate we get those there
there are three sources um for our lists
of of sites one is that against C
Shapiro article another is is from a
site that was up for a while called MIM
random colors and another is from a
paper that that we wrote where we were
we U used a semi-supervised learning
technique where we had dig votes we had
a few people that we knew what their
what their um what their uh liberal
conservative position was and we had a a
a few hundred articles that we hand
coded or we had mechanical turkers hand
code and and then we propagate and and
we get a uh a coding for for the rest of
things so all three of those lists give
us sort of Left Right score for each of
the sources
yes so I guess the were more partisan
than what people
read you just told us a figure second
that actually people read read both
articles but they don't necessarily up
both articles uh we we definitely found
there there was there was a lot of
signal in the uh in the Dig votes
uh if we if we knew that you were from a
group that was uh you know act
especially because the the people that
we knew of uh were people who had joined
groups that labeled themselves on dig as
as as as liberal or conservative and
even some of the traffic on those groups
was things about let's go up vote this
article together so that we can uh M
make this uh get this exposed to more
people
yeah uh this is I guess a simplifying
assumption that everything falls this
linear spectrum of liberal and
conservative uh does this work well in
practice or is reducing dimensionality
problematic right so we are reducing
things to a single Dimension here and
obviously that doesn't capture the whole
world it doesn't capture people and it
doesn't capture articles or or sources
perfectly but it is but it it's
correlated enough so that you can see
Trends uh and uh and it is it is the
same Dimension that people are used to
seeing Whenever there are pundits on TV
and and things like that so when you ask
people where do you stand some people
will say you know I'm an independent and
you can't classify me uh and but but
many people will say no I'm a liberal
I'm a conservative and this only works
for this only works for the people who
uh who fit somewhere on this one
dimension in a neat way and it doesn't
it won't tell us very much about the
people who you know
are all over the place on different
issues all right so we have that that
coding of the sites uh we got people to
install this browser extension uh and
then the extension is able to capture
their history for 30 days before they
installed the browser extension we ask
them a bunch of questions including
what's your political leaning uh and
then we randomize them to a treatment or
a control condition
the uh the treatment condition is that
they got to see the feedback and the
control was that they got nothing I'm
not sure what happened to
my I lost my illustration of what the uh
the treatment and control look like but
the the treatment you've seen and the
control instead of showing you whether
you're falling off one way or the other
or happily balanced it just says how
many days until we're going to give you
the feedback so it's a little countdown
timer 28 days 27 days 26 days the reason
the reason we need to do a control
condition even though we're comparing
before installation to after is that we
need to do a difference and difference
anybody who signs up for this is going
to have some effect from being in a
study and having thought about it and
signing up so we do see an effect of
everybody from their history to
afterwards and we have to compare what's
the difference in in in that change uh
between the people who get the feedback
and the people who don't get the
feedback all right so we recruited sub
subjects for a couple months uh word of
mouth it's in the Google extension
directory a lot of it was was from some
media mentions in in Tech blogs uh we
got a bunch of people to install it
1145 990 of them completed the survey so
those are the people who who were were
using uh they
were
liberal uh and and you'll see we we've
divided up in the results that we have
uh we statistically significant results
for the Liberals we don't get
statistically significant results for
the conservatives even though it looks
like a a larger effect because we just
don't have enough of them uh so they
they are four would be neutral and
they're leaning you know more than a
point on average towards the liberal
side uh they're also um
80% uh male and
uh age not not so badly skewed but so
there's some some issues of
representativeness of the sample it's a
convenience sample it's people who who
thought they wanted people who agreed
with this Norm people who thought they
wanted to be nudged and the question is
even for them does it does it work to
nudge them so we compute their their uh
their balance score this is the uh the
average score of all the all the sites
they visit and we we made this on a 1 to
11 scale because we had 11 pictures uh
and right in the middle six was the
perfect happy balanced guy uh and then
we uh just so that it's easy to to think
about this for both liberals and
conservatives if you were a liberal and
you mostly were reading liberal stuff
you end up with a positive score and if
you're conservative on this ra measure
we're just normalizing it to to which
side you are uh if you're conservative
and you're mostly reading conservative
stuff you get a a positive score on this
ra measure two hands were up here yeah I
was wondering how that you sort of um
put this in context with some of the
social psych Literature Like Jonathan
hates stuff with the pillars of morality
and how you know liberals on the whole
are more open to you know new
experiences and stuff like that whereas
conservatives prefer you know comfort
and and things they're familiar with and
so forth because that kind of might
explain that skew and also you know my
like would you know based on that
research there's a question of are
conservatives of even interested in
something like this or even interested
in in being nudged if it's you know some
not something that they value or not
something that they identify with with
things like that yeah so uh there are
some theories out there that say
Liberals are are
more uh more likely to expose themselves
to challenging things because they have
they value openness and that's openness
is not something that's especially
valued uh for conservatives so that
might give you you know some priors a
theory about how you think this might
come out you might also use that to say
well that's that would tell you who
would sign up for this I would not take
our sign up data as evidence for that
hypothesis um because I think the the
places where it was advertised are also
liberal skewed uh so it may just be you
know who heard about it and not who was
interested it I'm not saying it's not
true I just say I don't think I have any
evidence for it even though even though
we have more liberals signing
up I was just going to ask about where
it was advertised or what the the
selection the thing that gave us the big
jump was uh was when when some some tech
news sources wrote about it and then
then we saw a whole lot of people sign
up so that's my interpretation is that
was a big source for
us okay so here are the
um here's the what did people uh what
were people scores be in the month
before they signed up so this is where
we're using the history and uh zero
would be they were perfectly balanced
and uh the y- axis is the number of our
subjects who are in each of these
categories so this is the number of
people who are about one you know a half
to one and a half skewed POS skewed
towards the stuff that was agreed
1 and2 to 2 and2 and so on so people
were skewed towards their side actually
the Liberals were skewed towards their
side we'll see in a minute what where
the conservatives were just question
about your data of the new sources sort
of what's the Distribution on that one
to 11 scale where they all come near the
Middle where they that's a good question
and I don't know I see it would I should
know and I just I don't have that sorry
that would would be a helpful thing to
have uh here's the conservatives uh I've
just f it downwards we also just have
fewer of them you can see that there's
you know maximum of 60 of our
conservatives who signed up yeah there
are more who are who are reading more
conservative stuff than we're reading
more liberal stuff but actually they're
less skewed than than our liberals
so maybe they the the only maybe the
only conservatives who sign up are those
who actually are fair and balanced I
don't know
um so this is the this is what we get
for the results at the end this is the
Delta of your post to your pre and if we
have a uh a negative it means they're
reading more more conservative stuff at
the end than at the beginning and if we
have a above zero it means they're
reading more liberal stuff at the end
than at the beginning and uh these are
the people I've divided into control and
treatment the
treatment it doesn't look so obviously
uh different here but it is uh there is
a difference between these and in a
minute I'll give you a substantive
interpretation of what these numbers
mean and it and it turns out it is also
statistically significantly different
for the uh for the for the people who
had too much conservative stuff at the
beginning and needed more liberal stuff
in order to be balanced we see uh an
even bigger
difference uh but the difference between
these two there's fewer of the people so
the this is not statistically
significantly different there was
another question over here yeah I I
don't know if this is the right time to
ask it but um I wonder like not all new
sources or news articles that people are
reading are equal right and so I'm
wondering if for example so I'm just
going to use my own bias as a liberal
here um if I were interested in this but
most of the conservative sources I were
seeing were sort of of antivaccine
anti-science anti- evolution and stuff I
could imagine that that pushes me
further toward being liberal rather than
if I read things less crazy um on the
conservative side um and I'm curious
whether that sort of factored into
things where you know even the New York
Times has been grappling with this where
if politicians say things that are
obviously false should they be calling
them out on it versus you know or just
reporting sort of the from a neutral
standpoint and things like that um yeah
so there's there's all kinds of stuff
that are abstracted away into these this
source is a 1.3 yeah and and also in my
the sort of the outcome that I'm looking
at is more exposure more diverse
exposure I don't know anything about how
people are interpreting what they see
are they looking at this stuff so they
can ridicule it and and would that be
bad I mean I mean part part of the part
of the arguments about about why diverse
exposure is is valuable say it's okay if
people are looking at it in order to
ridicule it they're still aware that
there's somebody who who has who has
that opinion now there's also stuff
going on where where uh there's really
ridiculous stuff by conservatives that
liberals love to look at that none of
the conservatives are looking at because
we love to see how dumb they are right
and and uh so there's all kinds of stuff
that's that's getting lost in
and uh but I think we get the we we get
the overall effect and the big thing
that I wanted to see is
if if uh people think that they should
be uh uh more balanced and therefore
they sign up for this thing or at least
they're just curious about how balanced
they are does the feedback move them and
it does move them modestly to give you a
sense so there's the statistical
significance
um to give you a sense of how how much
that is uh that that the median
difference or that mean difference for
the median liberal reading user and the
median liberal leaning user had 187
visits over the course of that of that
month to news
sites uh for them that whatever 0.13
difference would be four new visit to
a Think Progress brib Drudge Report kind
of place or 20 new visits to a to a
neutral site so if they were you know
reading huffing post then if they read
20 more neutral things that would also
bring the the average in so this is you
know on 187 visits having four visits to
the to the right or 20 extra neutral I
think that's actually a fairly large
difference uh it's not it's not it's not
negligible my conclusion is that yeah it
it works a bit James know these
participants are um first of all someone
who is likely to install this
particularly more active in reading news
because just that that's you know kind
of like six visits per day or something
soon kind of hide to me on average these
news junkies kind of um that you
really I I don't know what the com score
average user is there any
other we we don't know a lot about these
people other than the survey we ask them
and the behavior that we have and the
survey asks them you know their age and
their their gender and their politics
and the behavior we have is is which
news sites they're looking at so yeah
this does look like a lot to me and it
also makes sense if you advertise we
have something that monitors your news
reading behavior and you don't read news
at all you're like I'm not going to
install
that yeah uh is that a dosage effect in
the sense that is does this work equally
well regardless of how liberal you are
or if if I'm very strongly liberal do I
have a much greater shift after
installing this because that guy is
falling now right right I I don't know
uh my guess is we don't have enough data
to to break it down that way but uh it
would be worth taking a look and and at
least seeing whe maybe something jumps
out at
us I want to uh go on and talk about a
couple more uh so that's one that seems
like I I think is somewhat promising
feedback people respond to feedback some
people some people respond to feedback I
don't think this is the be all and end
all but it it's it says yeah if we care
about this this is one thing that's
worth pushing on some more second idea
that we explored and and this is going
to be a less happy
ending so you're just so you're aware
aware of what's coming um is that we
made a news aggregator where uh we're
going to ask we're going to give people
a set of news articles every day and
we're gonna ask them how they like
it and different days different if you
come back multiple days you'll you'll
get a different mix of of uh liberal and
conservative stuff we're deliberately
varying how how much and we're seeing
you know does does does a 50-50 mix
versus an 8020 mix how does that affect
your
satisfaction and we're trying to see
whether telling you hey these is this is
the stuff we you'll agree with the
yellow stuff or not telling you does
that does that make a difference in your
satisfaction
especially your satisfaction with the
the mixes that have more challenging
items so we recruited people by
Mechanical Turk we did some
qualification tasks in quality control
I'm not going to go through details here
because I'm see I'm running way short on
time um if they don't tell us their
politics or if they say they're a
liberal Republican or a conservative
Democrat we throw them out because we
don't know what to do with them but if
they're but if they're if they're
consistent on those two then then we
include them uh and then they can come
multiple days each day uh Shan was
getting up each morning and and checking
what the news was and and making our
aggregator people were all over the
United
States um and we had
uh all right so the articles that we're
getting is uh mostly automated so we're
we're he had 500 political blogs and he
was seeing what they were linking to
automatically um but then uh then we did
some filtering if you had an article
that liberal and conservative blogs were
both linking to in equal amounts we
didn't use that we only used the ones
where there was an imbalance mostly
liberals or mostly conservative blogs
are are linking to it and we also got
rid of Wikipedia articles and some other
stuff um so we end up with about 23
items 23 Li and 23 conservative items
each day some of the people get their
mixture of of of Articles uh just
unlabeled and unsorted some of them get
them labeled with the yellow highlight
for stuff that
is agreeable to you and some of them get
all the agreeable stuff first and
highlighted just to give a sense of you
know here's what it looked like when it
wasn't just a thumbnail you would get
uh a title and a and a little snippet
for each of the Articles and at the end
we're asking
you how satisfied are you with the stuff
you got so our outcome is going to be
how satisfied they
are that's what's on my y- AIS the
x-axis is what percentage of the items
that we gave you that day were agreeable
and so as you might expect and actually
we're only taking we've filtered out
there were some people who actually
liked getting a
mix they said they liked getting a mix
and then we we looked at their data sure
enough they were happier when they were
getting a mix we're we're sort of
filtering those people out and then
we're s we're we're looking at at at the
people who liked it better when there
was more agreeable items and uh did the
highlighting help
no uh it seemed to actually amplify
their pre their preference so they like
the all agreeable stuff even more when
they can when when they can
tell uh and they they like the all
disagreeable stuff even less when they
can tell when they're not forewarned
about exactly where these things are
coming from they're a little bit more
muted in their preferences so not
successful
there and uh if we do the highlighting
and the Sorting uh it's even worse
they're just less satisfied all the
time except except when they except when
they're getting all agreeable stuff and
then then it's okay um but okay so this
this manipulation at least the day that
we have the particular implementation
not successful I'm not ready to say
don't ever try this uh but I'm also not
saying you definitely should because we
don't have good evidence for it uh all
those those claims
of of the slopes being different or The
Intercept being different hold up in the
statistical analysis as
well okay third third uh idea is to take
is similar to that except instead of
sorting and highlighting we're now going
to sort and put boxes around things that
are all the
alt conservative and all the mainstream
conservative and all the mainstream
liberal things they're each going to go
in their own
box and we're going to do that not for
all the news of today but all the news
about one topic so if you're reading one
topic this makes it easy to find other
things on the same topic so we actually
prototype this although we haven't
released this is in the wild yet the
idea is that you're um you're using uh
your browser and you're reading a news
story and you can pop up recommendations
for other news on the same topic and
those things will be grouped into into
clusters clusters 1 two 3 and four here
uh this is work with sadar chabra and
and Sunil
Park so Sunil had done this done an
experiment with uh Korean news uh where
he took all the articles about one topic
and then clustered them by subtopics so
what words are being used in in one set
of Stories versus another which might
capture some ideological differences but
might not might capture other things uh
he found that when they presented the
the set of other articles on the current
topic just in a random order the sort of
Google News Style people read fewer
articles and they got fewer aspects
fewer topical aspects of the of the
story so instead of four articles per
topic they were getting
2.56 and he thinks it's good evidence
for the fact that it's it's the
um it's
the sorting by subtopic that makes the
difference not the having boxes because
if we just have boxes and randomly put
things into the different clusters that
doesn't make people read more articles
so we get the 2.68 and 2.56 are
basically the same what makes people
read more articles as if the Clusters
were
meaningful so we wanted to take this
idea and say what happens if we do it
with political clustering instead of
topical clustering so you're reading
this is you know year and a half ago but
uh McCain was not happy with Janet
Yellen for the Federal Reserve and so uh
this is an article in NBC criticizing
that case uh that's coming from sort of
a mainstream liberal publication cluster
one is the alt liberal Huffington Post
Think Progress uh cluster three is the
Washington Times and Fox News sort of
mainstream Conservative then you've got
breit Bart and Blaze and cluster 4 so
you see one article and you say I wonder
what
some other people from some other
perspective are saying about McCain and
Yellen and you can you can see it we
wanted to see what the effect of this
would
be versus just having those same stories
not
grouped by
ideology how many of you think well I
already told you what's G to how it's
going to come out so I'm not going to
ask you but there but there are
competing predictions here for what
should happen from the social science
literature I think if you just take the
the this whole selective exposure
literature saying that people are averse
to challenge and they have you know they
the reinforcement bias and so
on uh that they should be less likely to
sample from both sides from a liberal
and a conservative Source if they can
tell that that's what they're
getting make it easier for people to
stay with the stay with
the amable stuff they will or you might
think that they would be more likely to
sample from both sides of course we have
the the analogy to the to the news Cube
study that made us suspect that and
that's why we're trying it uh but there
are also some some substantive reasons
that you might that you might come up
with um maybe people actually want to
find New Perspectives and this makes it
easier to find those uh the fact that
that this is in the context where
they've already had have easy access to
things that will reinforce their
opinions if I come across something
that's really challenging I can at least
Retreat and find out you know find out
why that was wrong and and someone will
be able to butress my my um my
values uh I think also the Clusters may
be making the diversity Norm more
Salient when you see them clustered like
that you say oh yeah I guess I really am
supposed to sample for more than one so
those are possible reasons why you might
get get
more so our experiment designed here
this is a simple AB test we're going to
randomly assign some people to get the
clustered recommendation some people to
just get in random order the
outcomes uh and this is sort of on each
story like McCain and Yellen uh the
number of Articles the person reads the
number of different Viewpoint clusters
they sample from and especially are they
reading from at least are they reading
at least one liberal and one
conservative
article
so they actually start they have a they
have a sort of a landing page where they
can pick news stories that they're
interested in so McCain was one of them
or Fox News is freaking out about Oprah
and race issues uh Obamacare forced my
mom into Medicaid so um these are the
we're trying to give participants some
choice they get to read about some story
that's of interest to them and when
they're tired of reading about that
story they know they can go on and read
something else they don't have to keep
reading articles on the same
topic um again we recruit subjects from
Mechanical Turk some not quite even uh
distribution in our
randomization uh we do get people
reading more articles when it's
clustered can you explain what was theef
that was to these like they just asked
to do the task without understanding
the I don't remember the exact wording
of the of what the hit says but it's
basically um test our news or our news
recommender uh read news for a couple of
minutes and and it said it said uh
you'll you have to read news for five
minutes you pick which stories you want
to read and then there was a countdown
timer they couldn't they couldn't they
couldn't quit before 5 minutes was up
but they could
leave McCain Yellen and go talk
about uh Nicole Hopkins or read about
Nicole Hopkins instead so they we're
trying to make it so they don't have to
to to keep exploring a story beyond what
they're interested
in and they each person only gets one
version or the other so they're
hopefully well we we'll talk about some
some of these limitations so they're
reading more stories uh or more articles
they are are uh they are sampling from
more
clusters and uh they're much more likely
to read both a liberal and a
conservative article when we have when
we have it clustered so here's the sort
of counts we have
uh these are the people who only read a
liberal story these are the people who
sorry a liberal article on the on the
current story these are people who only
read a conservative article and uh these
are people who read both a liberal and a
conservative article
yeah preference for example more
commonly just to read whatever articles
are up in the upper left corner of the
page yes and I'll talk about that was a
mistake in our in our design uh well in
our case upper right corner but uh yeah
um we didn't counterbalance the order
and that's that's one of the questions
I'm going to be asking for your advice
on how how much counterbalancing we
should do uh so people are people
are reading first from the
non-mainstream liberal which was the top
group so this is this is the first
article they look at and most people are
looking at a non mainstream liberal
article first some people are reading a
mainstream liberal article that was the
second cluster a few people are reading
a mainstream conservative and not very
many people are going all the way down
to the the fourth cluster but here's the
second article that they look
at and you can see there's uh uh this is
the unclustered interface there's some
um yeah there there are some people who
um who after they read one article from
non-mainstream Liberal are going to read
something else and I've sort of used a
darker font when people are sort of
switching sides from the current article
not a darker font but a darker shade um
when they're switching from one to the
next there's some people who are
switching this is the unclustered
interface but with the clustered
interface there's a lot more people who
are switching sides so we have a similar
distribution for the first thing that
they look at but the second thing they
look at much much more likely to be from
a conservative Source when it's
clustered so I take this as of a
positive sign but it really would be
interesting well what if they didn't
always choose a liberal thing first if
we maybe if we reverse the order so let
me talk about those
limitations so there there are issues of
representativeness and quality control
with with Mechanical
Turk uh there's The Ordering of the
Clusters we always
had alt liberal at the top and all
conservative at the
bottom
uh what were the subjects really
thinking when they did this this was
somebody asked the question of uh you
know what what were the instructions and
uh we had a reviewer who raised the
question maybe people thought that you
were testing that this was a test of the
interface and not of the news
recommendations and so they clicked on
all the things that they were to click
on in the
interface might be possible there's more
things to click on when there's more
boxes so I should click on more boxes if
I think this is an test which I think is
possible there's also the external
validity people are coming to this
they're looking at it they're reading
one story it's not part of maybe they
maybe they never read news at all or
it's not part of how they usually read
news so we have plans for a follow-on
study for this to to uh try to satisfy
our reviewers and ourselves that uh that
this result really is robust so we want
to try to this both as a Mechanical Turk
study and as a lab study do a little bit
better quality check at the end like
tell us what the story was make sure
that they weren't just letting the timer
run down for five minutes um and then I
randomize the order of clusters I'm
going to ask you in a minute how much
how random we should make it um some
small interface changes to not suggest
interface exploration and and sort of a
careful fine Toth comb over the
instructions for the external validity
eventually when we want to put out this
browser extension so that we let people
use it in their natural setting the
problem there is you have to actually
make good suggestions of other articles
and I it's doable but we have we haven't
yet gotten to something that we're ready
to to put out in the wild for that so
here are the questions that I I want to
ask you we can just have two possible
orders liberal to conservative and
conservative to liberal or we could try
all permutation
from an experimental design standpoint
you might think it be better to try all
the
permutations uh but from a user
standpoint we think of things along this
liberal to conservative Dimension and so
what do you think here well just from
just one step higher I mean it seemed
like you're almost testing two different
interfaces the first was a
recommendation one where I might go and
see how many things match interest and
the second is a clustering interface I
mean
uh the two the two things are both
recommending the same set of articles
but in the first one it's being
presented as a single list like Google
and in the second one I'm testing the
value
ofer so so we're talking about this
versus the other and you think so I
would be the first one like oh these are
Google results that relate to you know
this thing not Google but I mean I would
look through and see same way I do on
the first page of Google which ones are
relevant to me so I'd probably be more
likely to just pick out the ones that
are relevant whereas in the second one
they're being presented as explicit
clusters and so you've asked me to
evaluate this interface and so I'm going
to evaluate it as a clustering interface
so I'm going to look for diversity right
so this is this is the argument that
well I'm saying that you were asking
this question about how to present the
cluster that was like that seems like a
much more fundamental issue well but if
if we so we have to convince people that
the task is not to evaluate the
interface the task is to evaluate the
recommend the what read whatever you
want find the things that you want to
read what that randomly cluster the
other ones well we could also include we
could include the uh like he did in the
original study include a random
assignment to clusters version that that
that might alleviate that concern yeah
James the two problems with methodology
and I don't know the right solution for
me is the facts of positioning and all
kinds of at least Western bias of how
you go read and so if that's not
counterbalanced in some way you're going
to get some effect there that's the one
issue and then the other issue how is
the one about you were looking at how do
you make sure they read it I'm being
paid just to go into this thing and and
that's going to be really impact a lot
of people are not necessarily going to
do the task of actually meeting and so
the question is what the results me
being if they're just clicking on links
to get paid one thing I've seen that's a
methodology issue with some of these
mechanical T tasks depending on what
you're trying to measure so one approach
I've seen to that kind of a scenario is
that upfront you're told that you're
going to need to like write an essay
arguing the point or like debate someone
at the conclusion of this so there's now
there's no like go read sort of like
you're going to debate this point here's
the information you've got uh five
minutes go right that one wouldn't work
for us because there's theory that says
when people think that they're going to
have to defend the their Viewpoint
they're much more likely to to expose
themselves to challenging things that we
don't want to we we don't want to make
it artificial in that sense uh we don't
want to know just just in those cases
whether the clustering has has the
effect but but but I mean what I was
thinking is we just tell them you're
going to be asked you're going to have
to to say what the story was about so we
if they can't if they can't say it was
about McCain and Yellen and the Federal
Reserve then then
ask well I think we can just ask them at
the end and if they fail that we throw
them
out yeah we can just yeah then we throw
them out if they if they don't meet that
quality check me so uh this isn't what
you asked but I think I think there's an
important distinction between someone
reading something and uh someone reading
something and thinking differently
having read
it and so I'm curious if we can get to
the second point which really seems to
be the goal
so uh and I wonder if what you want is
sort of a dilemma question at the end
where you have to split some amount of
money or something like that with
someone who has an opposing view then
you do and see if this split better or
worse when when you give these
clusters yeah I we we could try to go to
some outcome that is you know have you
changed your mind or do you can you
there are things for example you know
can you what how big an argument
repertoire can you recite um um but but
this is a test of what are we able to
change what people look at it's not it
isn't a test of does it change people's
mind so if we can't change what they
look at then you know if we can't even
get them to look at the other side
then I don't think we're going to also
get them to to consider the other side
so this is a you know it's it's an
intermediate step to to where you'd like
to get
to okay I I I will see by what you're
saying just if I'm aware that there are
other points of view even if I don't
read those articles then I might have a
more encompassing view than so it could
be that just showing the other points of
view is are they don't have they don't
have to click through yeah so I will
give you my answer your question um and
my answer I got answers to other
questions which was which was also good
my answer will be along lines of what I
think most reflects the two choices that
we have on the internet as it is think
so for a cluster naming I think you
should name them in terms of like
liberal conservative blw because over
time people are going to realize that's
what the Clusters are when I pick up the
New York Times I know this is the
mainstream liberal cluster when I pick
up the Wall Street J you know so like
over time even if you don't label like
it in the long run that'll be what it is
and if people pick only from the pile
the cluster that they you know already
belong to then that's telling you you
know essentially I I feel like your the
results that you have was a good stand
um and I uh if if you did that I mean
presenting it differently as like oh C's
the liberal slant here's the
conservative slant people who want to
have that Curiosity satisfied of what
other people will think which I think is
natural in many of us and I don't ever
get to it just because it isn't
presented to me you know once it's going
to work for you presented will uh and at
least enable you to do that and the
opposite of that is like just the long
Google list of Random
stuff that people kind of read until
they're bored and don't get a a view of
that sampling so that's my instinct is
also to to name them my only problem is
that I then I can't do the the the um
the random clusters the random
assignment to clusters because that only
works if the Clusters aren't named I
personally don't think you need you
don't think I need that all right good I
hope we get you as a reviewer um so I I
think preferable to Cluster one two
three would be to just have no naming
label and just have a Graphic Design
element which shows that they're grouped
okay so yeah so that's that that might
be how we could B we might we might
preserve yeah so we might we might
preserve the U ability to do the the uh
random assignment that way yeah or I
would add a tag um just like a design
tag just next to any every link that say
this is mainstream liberal and then
randomize the links uh on every refesh
and see what is the behavior if if I
tend to agree with conservative content
and when I find the first link to be
conservative and I click versus if I
find it liberal and I don't click so we
could go back to the sort of the the uh
the labeled but not sorted in not sorted
into
Andes clustering versus nonclustered is
sort of like interface bias well but but
it's emphasizing this Norm of you ought
to be exploring other things there's a
reason there's a reason why you why you
would do it if you were making a nudging
interface
okay John and I have one last thing that
I want to throw up as a question I know
I won't get to hear the answers the
permutations I mean I would tend to
think that just the two would be useful
uh but another factor is uh my
affiliation so if I'm liberal and it
goes liberal conservative versus Liberal
conserv Liberal you'd have to account
that I think well I can either randomize
and and then analyze afterwards or I
could or I could do something deliberate
based on it but I don't really have a
strong theory about I guess I do have a
theory I think if you're liberal I want
to put the liberal stuff first because I
think you'll be more open to seeing
something conservative after you've
looked at something
liberal but but I think I think I want
to try both ways and and get evidence
for that and and I had a general
question about I mean this news reading
this task is there any kind of attempt
to how this task relates to have they
already read their news for the morning
anyway I mean so have they kind of
already gotten their take on this issue
and then they're doing this totally you
know what's the relationship of this
task relative to that so this could be
this is another external validity yeah
thing of you know if if somebody's
already read all this stuff about that
story then they're going to spend less
time with it here I think that I think
that ends up being sort of having some
people who are just less interested in
the topic probably is is a uh you know
is a source of random error rather than
bias for me
but good also a good thing to think
about and Michael can you hold it
because I want to get my last question
up and I know we're at 2 o'clock which
is I spent a little time a lot of time
with another former student Daniel Joe
who who finished his PhD and really
wants to be an entrepreneur trying to
take some of our automated
classification Technologies and things
to try to make a business uh sort of a
social Venture uh where we get people to
have more diverse political exposure and
our first attempt in this space was
let's make a news aggregator or a
recommender something that will get
people the stuff that they want for
those people who do want diverse
exposure and we actually found we we did
our if any of you have sort of done your
taken entrepreneurship classes we we
went to the NS I core program and they
made us go out and do customer Discovery
and so we found there are people who
would want that but nobody who would
want to pay for
it what we seem to find that people
wanted to pay for was to get other
people to be more
balanced works right if you'll pay me
I'll read other stuff okay so so we uh
so that's the thing that we've been
exploring now and we thought that people
would pay to get other people to do this
but actually we haven't uh we we thought
we had a clever way that we would get
people to to be willing to be the uh the
recipient but we actually didn't we we
have not found organizations that want
to pay to get people who don't already
agree with them to be exposed to their
message is this
ad no they they actually go for people
who are predisposed to like the thing
but maybe aren't aware of it and
and
individual so I have my opposite VI
Facebook and then I want to pay like get
him you know reading this other stuff
right yeah maybe they maybe we can go
direct to individuals that's anyway I
mean I mean I think if you're like an
extremely liberal Source then maybe it's
not worth it to advertise to like
extremely conservative people but if you
can find the people that are sort of
borderline and like nudge the Border a
little further it seems like something
that'd be very valuable this is how
political campaigns do it right yeah
well they the political campaigns are
spending a lot of money to try to avoid
reaching the opposition because it's a
way because they're spending a little
bit of money to avoid wasting their
effort on the people that they think
they have no chance on they' also like
to avoid spending it on the people they
absolutely know their set they really
want to focus on creeping this SP
forward uh well actually the political
campaigns are these days are very happy
to reach the people who are who who they
know they're going to get to make sure
that they actually go out and vote so
they they put a lot of effort in to get
out the vote they put some effort into
people who are Maybe you know leaning
their way but but haven't come yet yeah
so efforts like these often benefit from
starting with a market Niche and so some
people are information seeking a lot of
this liberal conver conservative stuff
has more to do with entertainment and
information MH if you can find a way to
identify people who are information
seeking and find a way to give them
choices of articles that are thoughtful
rather than entertainment oriented or
shouting heads kind of things um that's
a plausible Market finding them giving
them a useful product that's the hard
part yeah I so I think we could get make
a useful product for them and I and we
did sort of we we're doing our
interviews I found I found somebody like
that who was uh he was the campus
Minister for um Presbyterian he's very
conservative but very thoughtful and uh
and you know I asked him to show show me
are you what are you doing he reads all
kinds of liberal sources and uh and you
know I say you know what if I could get
you just the ones that were actually
thoughtful because he was you know
complaining about the stuff it wasn't
thoughtful and he he said actually I
found
them so that I think the problem is the
people who really want that feel like
they've sort of already found what what
they need now maybe maybe you know I'm
I'm overgeneralizing from not enough
data and maybe there are people who who
would pay for something like
that maybe one final comment
do you want to take the prerogative
since I cut off your last question who
had their hands up maybe was it someone
who hasn't said something before any new
voice gets the last
comment okay yes uh so on your previous
uh one there's another option which is
going from moderate to extremist right
so essentially just kind of like on on
the side in terms of the cluster
ordering uh but the question I want to
ask was back during the part where you
had the orders and the highlighting
right um You had a result which was that
if you put the things that you're most
likely to agree with on the top it's
actually put decrease the amount that
you like the result right I think that
was yeah why like that's kind of C to
like what the search do right they put
the things you want and like they feel
things won't like and they assume that
they'll make you happier right so we're
not sure uh we have one speculation that
it was an artifact of our of where we
put the
question the question was at the
bottom right after you saw it so if all
the stuff you like was at the top and
then the stuff you don't like is right
after and then we ask you the question
we think that might be
why and we don't we don't have any other
good explanation for it so that there
are POS there are you know could be
anything we don't know but
okay